[Musique]
et voilà vous comme ça la télé ça paraît
tout simple le vousz mêmewingine je
crois ah oui assurément c'est sûr on va
passer maintenant au résultats allez
basball 10e journée et dernière journée
d'ailleurs de Division 2 les cougard de
monttinis se déplaçai chez le 4e les
corvers de duner les joueurs d'arnaaufo
se sont facilement imposés le matin 175
et 152 dans le second match l'après-midi
2è à la fin de la saison régulière ils
peuvent désormais se concentrer
uniquement sur les play-offs à la fin du
mois d'août athlétisme maintenant au jeu
méditerranéen de qui se déroulit à
mererscine en Turquie laleuse de
l'Entente Athlétique de 50 ans en
Eveline aet Diwara a terminé au pied du
podium en finale du 100 m a avec un
chrono de 13 secondes et 34 cenè c'est
sa meilleure performance de la saison
mais ce n'est pas encore synonyme de
qualification et de minima pour les
championnats du monde mi-août ah benah
c'est
dommage encore il y a encore 6è à gagn
ça va être difficile tennis maintenant
Roland Garos après le le tournoi du
grand schlem Roland Garos accueillit les
championnats de France Jeune catégorie
13- 14 ans il y a quelques jours et le
Plaisirois Luc fomba classé 36 a atteint
les demi-finale vous le voyez à l'écran
il y a peut-être encore ici la relève du
tennis français et du côté des ivelines
et ben oui comme toujours il y a
beaucoup de choses du côté des ivelines
qui se passe on va maintenant à la base
de loisir de 50 ans en Yveline après un
printemps très humide et une baisse de
fréquentation de 10 à 15 % la base de
loisir de 50 ans Yveline a déveler ce
jeudi son programme sa programmation
pour cet été les amateurs de sensation
fortes pourront s'essayer à la TI relien
au-udessus de l'ÉTS longue de 150 m en
plus des traditionnelles animations
estivales évidemment le président de la
base de loisir Bernard Tabari espère
évidemment le retour du soleil et nous
explique le programme qu'il y aura lieu
cet
été nous sommes très inquiets et même
pour pas vous vous le cacher un peu
catastrophé par le printemps qu'on a eu
qui qui n'a pas permis effectivement de
de bénéficier des des beaux weekends
qu'on a la plupart du temps au printemps
mais bon on espè on que les mois d'été
vont rattraper ça ça va être évidemment
la la la piscine à vague avec tout ce
qui se passe
autour avec également le le village
sportif organisé par la la région qui va
permettre d'accueillir quelques 2000
jeunes des quartiers en difficulté et
qui vont pouvoir pratiquer des activités
diverses et
variées et puis bien sûr cette
tyrolienne qui va apporter un petit un
petit petit événement supplémentaire et
concernant le déménagement du centre
d'entraînement du parisain-germain
Bernard Tabari nous a indiqué que pour
l'instant le projet semblait être tombé
dans l'oubli concernant voà c'est fini
pour ce 7 sport dernier de la saison oui
tout à fait merci beaucoup Catherine
merci de l'avoir suivi et n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs encore à le commenter sur les
réseaux sociaux et Twitter avec le
hashtag tout attaché le 78 sport bonne
soirée et bonne été